نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
باستخدام كل انواع الاسلحه وتحويل اجزاء
من اوكرانيا الى رماد
تتحدث نحن ندعم اوكرانيا خوفا من روسيا
وليس حبا في الاوكران وربما تدعم العمليات
الروسيه من خلف ستار والاتحاد الاوروبي
يتودد للتغطيه على الامر محاوله اوكرانيه
فاشله لاستنساخ اسلحه الدب الروسي طوارئ
بوتين تتحرش بالنيتو والجيش الروماني
يتاهب بعد اعلانهما مواصله الدعم لكييف
واشنطن تسحباني وعودهما سريعا حيث يتحضر
ويدعم كسوفه لردع صربيا جيش التنين الصيني
الخفي يخترق الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
من جديد الحوطيون يدخلون البحرين الى
دائره اهدافهم وتعاون عراقي اردني يدخل
التاريخ
النيتو يتراجع اذا كانت اوكرانيا ليست
عضوا في النيتو ولا تنتمي للاتحاد
الاوروبي فما الذي يجعل الغرب يستميت في
دعمك تاتي الاجابه من الجانب الامريكي على
لساني مساعد الرئيس الامريكي لشؤون الامن
القومي الذي قال ان الولايات المتحده تدعم
اوكرانيا خوفا من الضغوط التي يمكن ان
تمارسها روسيا على حلف شمال الاطلسي بعدها
هزيمه اوكرانيا اليس لديكم اي تقدير
لاوكرانيا هذا على ذات الطريق تمضي القاره
الاوروبيه حيث ذكرت وثيقه سريه ارسلتها
اوكرانيا الى حلفاء غربيين ان طائرات
مسيره ايرانيه صنع استخدمت موسكو لشن
هجمات على مدن اوكرانيه بداخلها مكونات
اوروبيه وفادت صحيفه
التي نشرت محتوى الوثيقه المسربه انكي
يفقدت الوثيقه لحكومات الدول مجموعه السبع
في اغسطس الماضي اليكم المصدر ذكرت وث
[موسيقى]
الشمس الخارقه الروسيه وذلك في مؤسسات
سوفيتيه لا يمكنها العمل بمعزل عن روسيا
وكانك لا تعلم بمقوله السابقين اعطي الخبز
لخبازه لنعد الى قاده النيتو والبدايه من
لندن التي لم تمر ايام قليله على اعلانها
عن دعمها الدائم لكييف ليخرج وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني في مقابله مع مجله هوس
ويصرح ان الاستمرار في دعم اوكرانيا بات
امرا صعبا وموجعا ما الذي استجد ليتغير
الموقف بهذه السرعه بالاسلوب ذاته وبعد
الاعلان عن دعم امريكي جديد لاوكرانيا
مجلس الشيوخ الى وقف المساعدات لاوكرانيا
لتجنب الاغلاق الحكومي في البلاد الجميع
يتراجع واوكرانيا وحيده يا ساده الى الحرب
الاوكرانيه التي اصبحت تخرج عن نطاقها بين
الحين الاخر فقد اعلنت رومانيا العضو في
حلف شمال الاطلسي انها رصدت انتهاكا
محتملا لمجالها الجوي خلال هجمات ليليه
شنتها روسيا
في منطقه الدانوب في اوكرانيا المجاوره
وبحسب وكاله روترز وقد طلب من سكان جالاتي
المواجهتين لميناء في جنوب اوكرانيا على
الضفه الاخرى من نار الدانوب الاحتماء
باماكن امنه ليتكشف وسائل اعلامي قامت
بنشر قوات اضافيه على طول حدود
بسبب مخاوف من انتقال النزاع في اوكرانيا
الى داخل اراضي الدول الاعضاء
الاوكرانيه اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اسقاط تسعه صواريخ اطلقت قوتك
على مقاطعه جنوب غربي روسيا فيما اعلن
الجيش الاوكراني ان هجمات روسيه استهدفت
140 بلده خلال 24 في مقاطعه
[موسيقى]
من عشرين اشتباك مع القوات الروسيه هذا
واعلنت القياده العسكريه الجنوبيه في
اوكرانيا اسقاط 30 مسيره فوق مقاطعه
اوديسا
في هجوم روسي واسع بعشرات الطائرات
المسيره على المناطق الجنوبيه وها هي
الدفاع الروسيه تعلن عن الحصيله بتكبيد
القوات الاوكرانيه خلال يوم واحد خسائر
فادحه بلغت 700 جندي بين قتيل وجريحه
وتدمير مستودعات للاسلحه وفقا ما يتحدث به
المصدر في الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه
ولا زلنا في اوكرانيا حيث صرح رئيس
الوزراء الاوكراني ديناسيميغل بان مشروع
ميزانيه البلاد العام المقبل ينص على
زياده الانفاق على الانتاج العسكري بمقدار
سبع مرات الى حوالي
مليار الدفنه اي مليارا ونصف المليار
دولار ياتي هذا بينما احتفلت موسكو بمرور
عام على انضمام المقاطعه الاوكرانيه
الاربع حيث ان الرئيس الروسي بلاديمير
بوتين المواطنين بمناسبه الذكرى الاولى
ليوم اعاده توحيد مناطق جمهوريتي
الشعبيتين ومقاطعتي خرسون مع روسيا
الاتحاديه ومن اوكرانيا الى صربيا حيث
اعلنت الولايات المتحده ان صربيا تقوم
بعمليه انتشار عسكري غير مسبوق على طول
حدودها مع كوسوفو نايه بالجراد الى سحب
قواتها يصرح منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
بالبيت الابيض جون كاربي بان حلف النيتو
في ضوء التصعيد الاخير في كوسوفو يعتزم
زياده وجود قواته الدوليه لضمان الامن على
الحدود مع صربيا الاحداث والتطورات اعلن
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي عن هجوم سيبراني
صيني
الخارجيه الامريكيه وقال ان الصينيين
سرقوا عشرات الاف الرسائل الالكترونيه
لموظفين في وزاره الخارجيه يعملون بشرق
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ الاتهامات الامريكيه
للصين بالتجسس تتواصل وسط توتر العلاقات
بين البلدين واختلاف سياسيتيهما تجاه
اداره الازمات في العالم الى البحرين نعت
قوه دفاع البحرين احد افرادها برتبه ملازم
اول توفي متاثرا بجراح اصيب بها في هجوم
للحوثيين على الحدود الجنوبيه للسعوديه
وبذلك يرتفع عدد القتلى في هذا الهجوم الى
اربعه عسكريين بحرينيين اعلن وزير
الكهرباء العراقي زياد علي فاضل انجاز
شبكه الربط الكهربائي مع الاردن بشكل كامل
كاشفا ان عمليه اطلاق التيار ستتم خلال
ايام واكد المسؤول العراقي التزام بعقود
الربط مع دول الجوار نسيم خط الربط
الخليجي السعودي
واعطت وزاره الكهرباء العراقيه وعودا برفع
حجم انتاج الطاقه الكهربائيه بحلول الصيف
القادم